I go in shatter the Colossus are two of
the most well-known and beloved video
games they're part of the whole nebulous
idea of a videogame canon testimonies to
what games are capable of both
mechanically and emotionally they
touched players lives and we have seen
very little like them since except the
Last Guardian a game existing in name
and brief previews only announced in
summer 2009 recently the Last Guardian
trademark was temporarily abandoned due
to an administrative error at Sony
America this is the second time sony has
let the trademark expire the United
States Patent and Trademark Office sent
a notice in july two thousand thirteen
stating the trademark needed renewal and
the call went unanswered but the
trademark was renewed within hours of
the abandonment and a Sony
representative told GameSpot that yes
the Last Guardian was still in
development but since that 2009
announcement we've gotten very little
other than promises that yes after half
a decade of development we are still
getting the Last Guardian we're going to
shed a little light on that today and
look into what happened I'm Alexa ray
Korea and this is the latest on the last
guardian
back in October 2005 ICO and Shadow of
the Colossus director Fumito hawada
revealed that he was working on a new
project for Sony's then newest console
the PlayStation 3 and at the 2009
Electronic Entertainment Expo team ico
and Sony formally announced the Last
Guardian an action adventure puzzle
hybrid game that seemed to incorporate
elements of both ADA's previous games
The Last Guardian is about a young boy a
bird and cat-like creature and their
burgeoning emotional connection at least
that's according to the first
announcements the year following its
release at the 2010 tokyo game show sony
announced the game would launch for
playstation 3 in the 2011 holiday season
but in april 2011 sony delayed the Last
Guardian pulling its holiday release
window and replacing it with a TBA at
the time etta said in a statement quote
to provide more challenging and better
quality of content to users and to
fulfill Sony first party Studios
obligations I decided to postpone its
release timing according to some sources
the game was far from done at this time
necessitating the delay but six months
later director Fumito away to formally
left team ico and Sony he would finish
the Last Guardian on contract the
following month executive producer Yoshi
Foose ahuyama left the project as well
and it would continue to lose staff in
the years that followed I got in touch
with several former team ico staff
members to ask why away de and hayama
left but they were unwilling to offer
comment cancellation rumors cropped up
and as if to fuel them retailer game
stops suddenly canceled all customer
pre-orders for the Last Guardian in fall
2011 Sony representatives stepped in to
say the game had not been cancelled
gamestop dropping pre-orders was just a
blip in their system just another bit of
policy but on august sixth sony
abandoned Last Guardian trademark for
the first time sparking another round of
cancellation panic three days later Sony
reclaimed the trademark and reiterated
that the game was still in production
the abandonment had been a clerical
error in mid-2012 Sony began introducing
the playstation 4 hardware to select
developers in earnest it was around this
time some of Sony's first party studios
began committing to in ramping up their
own ps4 projects based on the
information we have it could have been
here or in late 2011 that talks at sony
japan studio turned towards bringing the
Last Guardian to ps4 this would explain
three more years of delay without new
visuals as the studio rebooted the
project for the new console generation
after the 2012 Tokyo Game Show kotaku
published an interview with an anonymous
sony developer who claimed the Last
Guardian was a very ambitious project
and had been announced far too early
according to the developer quote I give
you my word that it exists we are
working on it there are lots of pieces
to the puzzle it's a matter of getting
them to fit together on februari 20th
2013 sony formally announced the
playstation 4 to the public during a
press conference in new york city among
the dozens of announcements from
developers making new games for the
system The Last Guardian was oddly
absent at the time Sony couldn't comment
on the status of the project but people
immediately assumed that the Last
Guardian would be a great fit for a ps4
launch title shortly before e3 in june
2013 the e3 insider website erroneously
listed the Last Guardian noting it would
be at the show and attendees would learn
the latest details sony was quick to
call this listing purely speculative and
sure enough the game was nowhere to be
found at the show then during a live
broadcast on Spike TV then president and
CEO of sony computer entertainment
america Jack Trenton stated that the
Last Guardian was on hiatus Q mass
hysteria among eager fans but by August
Sony had quashed rumours that
development had stalled in an interview
with fem itsu Kuwaitis said that we
should temper our expectations for the
last guardian for the time being quote
it's under earnest development however
SE japan studio who's working on the
Last Guardian also has titles like
puppeteer and knack and those are the
only ones currently announced those are
taking priority right now that October
president of Sony worldwide studios
Shuhei Yoshida said the game was
undergoing a re-engineering the no
further explanation for what that meant
was offered the term re-engineering
strongly hints at a core upgrade again
leaning towards the ps4 the following
month away to publicly apologized for
the wait for the Last Guardian stating
the titles release conditions were at
this time beyond his control the weekend
before e3 2014 a number of Russian sites
ran stories stating a Sony Russia
representative
then the Last Guardian was canceled
IGN's us site was told The Last Guardian
wouldn't appear on any platform Sony
took to social media to stamp out the
flames with software product development
head for Sony worldwide studios America
Scott Road responding to tweets stating
the Last Guardian had not been cancelled
during e3 Road told GameSpot that Sony
would show the game when it was ready
last summer Yoshida told press that Sony
had a timeframe in mind for revealing
the Last Guardian echoing Road
statements about only showing the game
when Sony felt it was ready then in
October your she'd had told weekly
Famitsu that the team was working
diligently on the game with development
going more smoothly than it previously
had been an interview with a waiter
published in an early December 2014
issue of dengeki playstation suggest
that all wrinkles in the last guardians
development had finally been rectified
according to the director quote talks
with sony computer entertainment on the
Last Guardian have been ironed out and
we're making progress under completely
new condition I'm also working on some
other things that I'll hopefully be able
to show in time if progress is smooth
these completely new conditions likely
mean a transition to developing the last
guardian for PlayStation 4 a sony has
been focused on its newest platform it
seems unlikely that the game would come
to both ps3 and ps4 given most of Sony's
recent first party titles including
infamous second son the order 1886 and
blood-borne are only available on the
newer console so what's the latest on
the Last Guardian it's hard to predict
whether or not we'll see the Last
Guardian at any major trade shows this
year III would be the obvious choice but
the last couple years of announcement
teases have left fans a little raw
another possible scenario is a rear
appeal at the Tokyo Game Show but given
a love for ICO and Shadow of the
Colossus in the West it's not hard that
Sony would want to honor those fans with
a big celebratory III announcement
that's all we have in the last guardian
for more news stay tuned to gamespot com
I'm Alexa ray Korea and thanks for
watching